اهلا يا وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي مترو
كوليبا بدل استعدادات الاستقبال انظمه
صواريخ باتريوت المضاده للطائرات من
الولايات المتحده وقال كلي بين اوكرانيا
تتوقع نشر هذه الانظمه في اقرب وقت ممكن
مضيفا بان الجهود جاريه بشكل مكثف لايجاد
حلول جديده في ما يتعلق بتوريد انواع
جديده من الاسلحه الغربيه واشار الى ان
اوكرانيا طلبت في المقام الاول دبابات
غربيه متطوره وعربه المدربه
هذا هو قال مسؤول الاوكرانيين الوقت قد
حان لارسال قوات حفظ السلام الى محطه زبرج
النوويه دون ابرام اتفاق مع روسيا لاقامه
منطقه امنه هناك واوضح رئيس شركه الوطنيه
للطاقه النوويه في اوكرانيا ان مفاوضات
وكاله الطاقه الذريه لا تحرز اي تقدم ولا
يوجد حل حتى
الانويه هي اضخم محطه اوروبا وتتعرض للقصف
والقطاع الكهربائي مرارا واثار مخاوف من
وقوع كارثه اشعاعيه فيما تتبادل اوكرانيا
وروسيا الاتهامات في القصر
وقد امر الرئيس الروسيه في نادي مير بوتن
بادخال الفرقاطه الادمره جورج شوف المزوده
بصواريخ سيركن فرط الصوتيه للخدمه
العسكريه واكد بوتن ان التسليح القوي
للفرقاطه سيحمل روسيا من التهديدات
الخارجيه واصفا بدء عملها بالحدث المهمه
جدا وبدوره قال وزير الدفاع الروسيه
سيرجيو ان روسيا ستستخدم صواريخ سيركن
خلال مهمه الفرقاطه الادمن او الادميرال
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا
بيربوك كان الرئيس الروسي بوتين لا يفكر
سوا في تدمير اوكرانيا وشددت في تصريحات
صحفيه بان من المهمه الاستمرار في تقديم
الاسلحه الاوكرانيه حتى تستطيع الدفاع عن
نفسها واشارت الى ان الاتحاد الاوروبي قام
بكل شيء لوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن
الجهود فشله
ومن جانبه كشف المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه عن السبب الرئيسي وراء الضربه
الصاروخيه الاوكرانيه التي استهدفت الجنود
الروس في مدينه مكيفكه ليله راس السنه
وعوده بالعشرات منهم مشيرا الى ان السبب
هو الاستخدام المكثف من قبل العسكريين
للهواتف المحموله
مستشفى
لكن من الواضح بالفعل ان السبب الرئيسي
لما حدث والاستخدام المكثف من قبل افراد
الفوز للهواتف المحموله ما جعلهم في
متناول اسلحه العدو وسمح هذا للعدو بتحديد
احداثيات مواقع الافراد العسكريين لشن
الضربه الصاروخيه يتم حاليا
اذا السيسي
محمد البابا محمد مرحبا بك معنا من
المعلومات المتوفره ولن حول اعلان وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني بدء الاستعدادات
لاستقبال انظمه الباتريات
يعني الجيش الاوكراني بدا يحضر لاستقبال
منظومات التي ستصل وهذه معلومات حصريه
لقناه العربيه خلال اسبوع
يعني هذه المنظومه بطريقه سريه وبطريقه
حتى لا حتى لا تقوم القوات الروسيه
ومن المتوقع انها ستكون في محيط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف هذا ما يتداول في اوصاف
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه وزاره الخارجيه
او اليوم موقف او ما اعلنه وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني ان اوكرانيا تستعد للحصول على
عدد على يعني منظومه به الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بتزويد اوكرانيا بمنظومه اضافه
ان الجانب الاوكراني وهذا يعني يتداول
الان في وزاره الدفاع الاوك عن حاجات ما
يحتاجه الجيش الاوكراني من اليات وخاصه
دبابات متطوره ويتداول اسم دبابات ابرامز
بشكل كبير لان الجيش الاوكراني هو في خلال
عمليه تحرير الاراضي الاوكرانيه في شرق
اوكرانيا ل- هو بحاجه لدب دبابات متطوره
تستطيع التعامل والتقدم خاصه عن الدبابات
ابرمز الامريكيه تعتبر من افضل الدبابات
العالميه التي يمكن وبحاجه اليها الجيش
الاوكراني في عملياته ولا ننسى ان
اوكرانيا حصلت على يعني ناقلات من نوع
سامسونج
113 وكان لها دور فعال في تقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه واستعاده بعض الاراضي في
مقاطعه حتى مقاطعه لكن تشغيل هذه المنظومه
محمد يعني همم امر معقد وتحتاج كذلك
الطواقم بشريه مؤهله ربما فهل الجيش
الاوكراني مستعده ان هناك يعني اخرين ربما
هم من سيق على تشغيل هذه الانظمه
الان في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لاستخدام هذه المنظومات وكما حصل مع
منظومه التي حصلت على نسمز التي حصلت
عليها اوكرانيا قبل فتره اثبت الجنود
الاوكرانيين فعاليتهم وبشكل محترف وحتى
حصلوا على يعني تنويه من الجيش الامريكي
عن كيفيه استخدامه لهذه المنظومه حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني نسبه نجاح هذه المنظومه فوق
صماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف نتكلم عن
منظومه هي 100% معظم الاهداف التي يعني
يستهدفتها منظومه استطاعت اصابتها
واسقاطها من صواريخ يعني روسيه من صواريخ
صواريخ كاليبر وايضا من يعني همم مسيرات
ايرانيه التي تطلقها بشكل يومي روسيا على
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف لذلك الجيش
الاوكراني هناك جزء كبير وعناصر من الجيش
الاوكراني تخضع للتدريبات على استعمال هذه
المنظومات كما حصل مع منظومات اخرى كما
حصل مع يعني بعض المدافع التي حصل عليها
الجيش الاوكراني من مدافع هاوتر ومدافع
سيزر الفرنسيه وايضا اليات ودبا يعني قطع
عسكريه من المانيا الجيش الاوكراني يحسن
استخدام هذه الاسلحه ويتعلم الجنود
الاوكرانيين وبفتره قياسيه على استخدام
هذه الاسلحه ماذا عن همم يعني
الاسلحه الاخرى التي طلبتها اوكرانيا هل
هناك معلومات بامكانيه توفيرها ربما خلال
الفتره القريبه القادمه
يعني انا ساتكلم بشكل يعني الجانب
الاوكراني يتكتم بشكل كبير عن طبيعه
الاسلحه التي يحصل عليها الا في حال اعلن
وزاره الدفاع ولكن يعني سنتكلم ان منظومه
باتريوت التي ستحصل عليها اوكرانيا خلال
اسبوعين على حد اكثر هي كانت حلم
لاوكرانيا قبل خمس او سته اشهر لذلك كل
سلاح يطالب به الجيش الاوكراني يحصل عليه
او اكرانيا تطالب به تحصل عليه بعد الفتره
وذلك بفعل اولا فعاليه الجيش الاوكراني
مصداقيه الجيش الاوكراني مع الدول الغربيه
لان قبل الحرب كان هناك تخوف من الدول
الغربيه عند حيث يعني كان هناك تقديم بعض
الاسلحه اللي تقع
بيد يعني مجموعات متطرفه ولكن ازمه الجيش
الاوكراني او قدم ثقه كبيره لا الدول
الغربيه التي بدات بفتح خزائن الاسلحه
وتسليها للجيش الاوكراني يمكن القول انه
في الفتره المقبله ولا ننسى ما قاله
الرئيس الاوكراني فيه الكونجرس قال ان
الجنود الاوكرانيين يستطيعون
يعني استخدام الطائرات الحربيه الامريكيه
والدبابات الامريكيه وهذا هو طموح الجيش
الاوكراني بالحصول على طائرات امريكيه
الصنع وايضا دبابات امريكيه الصنع وهذا ما
يعني بعيد او خلف الكواليس يمكن ما تطالب
به اوكرانيا بشكل يومي من كل حفائها
بالحصول على اسلحه متطوره صحفيه محمد
البابلي كيف شكرا جزيلا لك
انتقد المبعوث الامريكي الخاص بايران
روبرت مالي كما السلطات للمحتاجين الشباب
وقال في تغريده له انه يتعاين على قياده
الايرانيه الاستماع وللشباب بدلا من قتلهم
واشار ماليه لان الشباب الايراني
عقوبه الاعدام بعد محاكمه سوريا
قد كشفت وكاله انباء تسنيم ممر
الايرانيتان عن لقاء مساعد رئيس الايراني
محمد حسين في وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان على هامش في حفله
تنصيب الرئيس لولدي السيلفا في البرازيل
مساعد الرئيس الاوكرانيه كذا حسب الوكاله
الايرانيه على ضروره استمرار المحادثات
التي بدات بين طهران والرياض في العراق
وفقا لوكالات انباء ايرانيه وتعليقا على
ذلك قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان الاجواء الحاليه
ايجابيه معربا عن امنه في عقد جوله جديده
من الحوار بناء على حسن النوايا على حد
قوله
ينضم الينا من الاستديو عبد العزيز بن صقر
رئيس مركز الخليج الدكتور عبد العزيز حياك
الله اهلا وسهلا
دكتور المتابعه
لتصريحات الايرانيه يجد ان هناك تهافت من
قبل خاصه الدبلوماسيه الايرانيه في توجيه
الدعوات للحوار مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اخرها ما قاله المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الايرانيه ان الارض ممهده لتحسين
العلاقات مع الرياض ولذلك حقيقيه
ولما مساء الخير لك استاذ خالد المشاهدين
العربيه في كل مكان الحقيقه يعني المملكه
لم تمانع من اقامه هذا الحوار يعني كان
هنالك حوالي خمسه جولات حواليه تم عقدها
في بغداد وتم نقاش في كثير من قضايا ولكن
الفرق ان السلوك الايراني لم يتغير في
المملكه لا تريد ان تعيد علاقه مع ايران
دون تغيير السلوك وجدنا حينما غير تركيا
من سلوكان المملكه رحبت باعاده العلاقه
واستقبل الرئيس اردوغان وزار سمو ولي
العهد حفظه والله تركيا ويعني الان تعادل
علاقه بكافه انشطتها الى ما كانت عليه
طبيعته الايرانيين لهم مصلحه في عهد
العلاقه المملكه لا تمانع من اعاده
العلاقه ولكن السؤال هو الذي يطرح نفسه
هنالك ما زال نفس السلوك الايراني سياسه
تدخليه سياسه توسعيه دعم الميليشيات
الموجوده التدخل في الشان العراقي ودعم
الحشد الشعبي للقيام حتى في مناطق حدوديه
قريبه المملكه ببعض التجهيزات التي وردت
حواليها بعض الاخبار المهمه في هذا الجانب
همم
النطاقها الاعلامي على سبيل المثال هي
تطلع وكاله الانباء الايرانيه تقول عن
مصدر لبناني او الصحيفه او تليفزيون اخر
انهم قالوا ان المملكه سوف تنفذ احكام
يعني كده شيء هي تشترط وتقول ان محطه
التلفزيون الايرانيه الناس التي يتبناها
المعارض الايرانيه هي هي ايضا
تتلقى معلوماتها من الداخل الايراني
كثير من الحقائق فيتضع يعني تجعل نقاط
اشياء في ظاهرها تبدي الرغبه لكن المملكه
لا تريد هذه العوده بالشروط الايرانيه
تريد ان تكون الشروط الايرانيه او على
ماذا تركز ايران اليوم في اي جوله محادثات
او مفاوضات او اعاده لرسم العلاقات مع
الرياضه بالدرجه الاولى هي تنكر اي شيء من
هذا التدخل تحت هي دائما تنكر طبيعه
الاعمال التدخليه التي تقوم بها هي تتدخل
في سوريا وفي العراق وفي اليمن وفي لبنان
يعني قامت فهي تنكر اول شيء هذا الجانب
وتقول انها تدعم طلب الحكومات الشرعيه
عند الجانب السعوديه
غير مقبوله ايضا هي تحاول استخدام البعد
الطائي في كوسيله ما ننسى انه ايران هنالك
تهديد على الممرات المائيه هي قامت به
تمام يعني بشكل واضح في منطقه الخليج وفي
ايضا مضيق باب المندب ال ال الضرب المنشات
النفطيه هي من قام بتوجيد طلباتي الى
جوبجيك المنشات السعوديه النفطيه هي من
تواجد في العراق ودعم هي من يعني يوجه
ضربات الى شمال العراق والتدخل في شان
العراقي في هذا الجانب فهذه كلها اعمال
يعني غير مقبوله البرنامج النووي
والبرنامج الصاروخي هو مسؤوليه دوليه
يتحمل مسؤوليه المجتمع الدولي وليس فقط
دول منطقه لكن دول المنطقه شعره حينما
يبرر لايران في المفاوضات عدم ذكر الاجند
الاقليميه هذا غير مقبول وغير جائز فلذلك
لا يمكن ان اقبل بمفاوضه مع الجانب
الايراني دون ان يقبل ان يدخل في تفاصيل
هذه النقاط والادله واضحه والنقاط واضحه
يعني لدرجه انه في احد الاجتماعات مسؤوليه
راني كان يقول لمسؤول سعودي تحدثه مع
الحرس الثوري الايراني انا مع من اتحدث
هذه النقطه تحديدا يعني في الوقت الذي
تاتي فيه تصريحات من الخارج همم الايرانيه
باعاده
حلقات وغيرها من الامور تصريحات ناعمه
تاتي في تتزامن مع همم اسماعيل قاني مثلا
على سبيل المثال والتصريحات التي يشم فيها
هجوم العده على المملكه العربيه السعوديه
من الذي يحدد اذا السياسه الخارجيه للنظام
الايراني هل هذه التصريحات تؤثر على اي
نوايا بالتالي وعلى اي توجه ربما محتمل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه في الدخول في
مفاوضات مع ايران املا يعني منذ فتره
السابقه يعني قبل الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي
وصوله الى السلطه كنا دائما نرى ان المرشد
الاعلى ومكتبه والحرس الثوري هم من يقررون
السياسه الداخليه في المنطقه لذلك حتى ما
حكمه ابراهيم رئيس وزير الخارجيه يعني
حديث من باب
انا اسمي توزيع الادوار في الجانب
الايراني وتوزيع الادوار هذه قضيه ولفنا
عليها لكن ال- ال- الذي بد في القرار هو
المرشد الاعلى وهو الحرس الثوري الايراني
هو الذي من يبد في هذا لانه هو من يعني
وجدنا زياره رئيس الحرس الثوري الى الى
العراق
لتحديد مواقع بالقرب من الحدود السعوديه
ويؤكدون على اهميه انتقال يعني مجموعات من
حشد الشعبي الى هذا المكان هذه قضيه غير
مقبوله يعني انت اعاده العلاقه على فكره
لها مستويات ممكن اعيدها على مستوى
القنصليه المستوى النائب السفير المستوى
السفير والمملكه مانع كظهار حسن النيه
انني اقبل بالالتقاء المباشر والتفاوض دون
ان يكون هناك وسطها نحن بحاجه الى وسطها
نعرف الاجنده الايرانيه وما يريدون وهم
يعرفون ما يريده لا نريد التدخل في الشان
الداخلي وعلى فكره المملكه حتى يعني لما
كان كل الحراك في داخل الايران هي لم تدلي
بتصريح واحد له علاقه بالحراك الداخل داخل
ايران لن تعتبر ان هذا شان داخلي ولا تقبل
في التدخل في شان الداخليه لاي دوله من
الدول لكن مع الاسف الشديد السلوك
الايراني بهذه الطريقه لا يمكن ان يكون
مقبول ولا يمكن لانه على فكره لو انا قبلت
اني اعيد العلاقه معه بهذا الوضع وبهذا
السلوك وبهذه التصرفات معناته اني انا
قبلت ضمنيا كل هذه التصرفات فرح تعطيها
المجال في التوسع كما يريد هل يمكن
التعويل على لان هذه القضيه بالتاكيد هي
مهمه ومؤثره للدول العظم يعني تحدث عن
روسيا التي لها علاقه كبيره مع ايران ومع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين بعد الزياره
الاخيره التي قام بها يعني الى الى الى
الرياض طيب بالتالي هل يمكن
التعويل هنا على وسط الروسيه الامريكيه
حتى صينيه ربما في اعاده التفاوض بين
الرياضه
ولكن بحاجه الى مواقف من هذه الدول واضحه
يعني بمعنى انه اذا كانت ايران هي من يدعم
الحوت في اليمن في ايران لها علاقه قويه
مع الصين كثير من اسلحتها وتصنيعها
واجهزتها وامدادها ياتي من الصين العلاقه
التجاريه الكبرى هي مع الصين ايضا روسيا
لها علاقه قويه احترافي هذا الجانب اذا
ارادت هذه الدول ان تستمتع وان ان ان
تستفيد من العلاقه السعوديه المتوازنه ما
بين كل الاطراف فعليها ان تقف موقف واضح
وهذا الكلام سمعناه في زياره الرئيس
الصيني الاخير حينما لاول مره يوجه بعدم
التدخل في شان الداخليه للدول الاقليميه
وكانت ايران مزعجه الامر اللي جعلها
تستدعي السفير الصيني في في في طهران
وتتحدث معه في هذا الجانب روسيا ايضا يعني
مصلحتها الحقيقيه تكون في ان تكون في
علاقه جيده مع الاطراف نحن نعلم مصلحتها
مع مع ايران ولكن من الواضح انه هذه
العلاقه مع طهران لن تمكينها من من اشياء
مستقبليه تريدها لا ينكر اننا بدانا مرحله
جديده في الحرب البارده وهذه المرحله
الجديده هي اعاده تشكيل التحالفات المملكه
استطاعت ان تحافظ على موقف متوازي من كل
الاطراف وهذا الموقف المتوازن هو الذي
مكانها ان ان ان تكون يعني في موقع افضل
بكثير من الغير والكل يلجا وياتي اليها
لياخذ الموقف لكاس اساس في الموقف القديم
في ضوء هذه المواقع يعني وربما اذا جاز
لنا وصف تحفظ ربما من الرياض تجاه اي
مفاوضات همم
بعيدا عن القضايا الجوهريه المهمه في
المنطقه اليمن الخليج التدخل في في العراق
سوريا لبنان وغيرها
وموقف ايران التي تريد فقط التركيز على
اعاده العلاقات بينها همم البلدين هنا كيف
يمكن النظر الى افق والتحديات التي يمكن
ان تشهدها المنطق في ضوء هذا التباين في
المواقف باستمرار الصراعات استمرار
المواقف الايرانيه في التدخل
المختلفه احد السنه يقول انه استمرار هذا
التصعيد في العلاقه ما بين المملكه و بعد
دول الخليج مع ايران ربما يدفع ايران
لتوجيه عمليات عسكريه واستخدام الهاردسك
وسيله ربما هذه يدفع ايران لدعم الحوثي
اكثر وتحفيزه لتوجيه ضربات جديده اخرى
سواء في الداخل اليمني في منطقه مارب او
على لبعض الدول خليجيه المجاوره هذه ربما
تكون رده فعل وتصعيد من الجانب الايراني
ولكن يجب ان نكون مستعدين عليها لانه
النقطه الاساسيه دائما في التفاوض كلما
قدمت تنازل فالطرف الاخر سوف يطلب المزيد
معه اعتبره مكسب وهيرا ان هذا ضعف المملكه
ليست ضعيف الحمد لله قادره ان تدافع عن
نفسه وقادر ان تتحمل تبيعات هذا القرار
وما ينتج عنه الدول الغربيه بما فيها
اوروبا يعني احنا الان نشعر بانه اوروبا
بدات تقاطع رسميا المانيا على سبيل المثال
كانت اكثر دوله لها علاقه قويه مع ايران
الان لا تستقبل الوفود السياسيه الان ترفض
بعض الانشطه او كافه النشاط الاقتصادي
والثقافي والسياسي
الدوري كمان
الموقف الامريكي اللي راى انه يعني عدم
قبوله بشيل قائمه الحرس الثوري وادخال هذا
الموضوع في المفاوضات البرنامج النووي لم
يقبل الامريكي بهذا روسيا والصين سوف
تستيقظ من سباتها يعني الان الصين بدات
تستيقر انا الان يعني اشعر بانه سين بدت
تشعر بعد زياره الرئيس الصيني واجتماعه
بالزعماء والقاده العرب والخليجيين تحت
مظله الزعامه والقياده السعوديه استشعلت
الصين بانه صحيح ايران علاقه مهمه لانه
افغانستان وباكستان واكبر دوله انا مصدق
لها في المنطقه ولكن بالمقابل العلاقه مع
بقيه الدول يجب ان تكون تراعى فيها
مصالحها الجوهريه والاساسيه شكرا جزيلا
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج شكرا
رابع مستمره في بعد قليل
اصدار واكثر من 4600 فاتوره ضمن المرحله
الثانيه من رسوم الاراضي في مكه وجده
والدمام
اهلا بكم من جديد
في السعوديه
منخفضت عقود التمويل كذلك بس 36% تفاصيل
مع الزميل
كشفت بيانات صادره عن البنك المركزي
السعودي عن انخفاض سنوي في التمويل
العقاري الانخفاض وحسب ما اوردته صحيفه
الاقتصاديه السعوديه بلغ سبعه وثلاثين في
المئه خلال نوفمبر حيث لم يتجاوز السبعه
مليارات و400 مليون ريال وعلى المستوى
الشهري سجل التمويل العقاري انخفاضا ايضا
بواحد ب 21% ينخفض بنحويه مليارين ريال
بين شهرين اكتوبر ونوفمبر من العامل
الماضي
انخفاضه حجم التمويل العقاري في نوفمبر لم
يكن امرا غريبا على العام 20 22 حيث شهدت
10 اشهر من العام من اصل 11 شهرا صادره
بياناتها انخفاضا سنويا كان اكبره في
فبراير الماضي حيث وصل الى ثمانيه وثلاثين
في المئه بعده نوفمبر بسبعه وثلاثين في
المئه في مكان الارتفاع الوحيد لشهر يونيو
حيث سجل ارتفاعا سنويا بلغ ثمانيه بلغ
ثمانيه وخمسين في المئه وحول المنتجات
السكنيه جاءت الفلل السكنيه الاعلى تمويلا
خلال 11 شهرا من العام الماضي باكثر من
تسعه وسبعين مليار ونصف المليار ريال ريال
شقق بخمسه و20 بخمسه وعشرين مليار ونصف من
مليار ثم الاراضي بثمانيه مليارات و700
مليون ريال والى اجمال العقود التي ابرمت
المصارف والافراد خلال نوفمبر الماضي فقد
بلغت نحو
9,70090,000 عقد وذلك بانخفاض قدره سته
وثلاثون في المئه عن نفس الفتره من العام
20 21
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم الينا
الخبير في الشهر العقاري خالد حياك اهلا
وسهلا فيكم
لانخفاضات كما هو ملاحظ مستمر يعني في
تمويل العقاريه هل يمكن قراءه هذا
الاستمرار باسباب مختلفه عن ما كانت عليه
في السابق بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على
رسول الله
كان متوقع طبعا مع ارتفاع الفائده
واستمرار حدد ارتفاع الفائده همم يعني كان
هناك توقعات ان يكون هناك انخفاض في حجم
الطلب على التمويل العقاري ايضا هناك
انخفاض في السيوله في البنوك هذه الموجهه
للتمويل العقارب هذا طبعا بالتاكيد حول
عدد كبير جدا من همم طلب على الشراء عن
طريق التمويل العقاري الى همم طلب على
الايجار خلال الفتره القادمه على الاقل
الى ان يتم همم يعني همم انخفاض هذا
الفائده
بالتالي الى اي منتهيه مؤثره على سوق
العقار الان لا شك انه هيكون لها تاثير
كبير جدا يعني انه جزء كبير من الطلب يعني
كان يتمثل اكثر من 60% تقريبا من الحجم
ترازاكشن او او عمليات الشراء خلال
الاعوام الماضيه كانت موجهه من قبل
المشتريين عن طريق التمويل البنوك لكن لا
ننسى ان هناك حجم ايضا كبير من طلبات
التمويل همم المدعومه من القرض المدعوم
وبالتالي همم يعني انا اتوقعاته انه خلال
فتره القادمه بالنسبه للطلب على همم
الوحدات السكنيه خاصه على القرض المدعوم
او العقارات المنخفضه الكلفه سيكون هناك
استمراريه في الطلب لانه همم اكيد انه لن
يشعر طالب تمويل همم لرفع الفائده لانه هي
اصلا الفائده بدعومه
بل هناك اي تاثير على مستوى اليسار
الوحدات السكنيه خلال الشقق وغيرها برايك
يعني هل في شيء ملموس من خلال انخفاض يعني
ما في شيء هيكون سريع يعني لانه هناك حتى
بالمقابل انخفاض في حجم همم المعروض لانه
كثير مطولين عقارين عندما وجدوا الارتفاع
الفائده اثر عليهم ايضا يعني سواء كان في
تمويلهم للمشاريع لتطوير العقاري وايضا في
شهيه المستثمرين معهم للدخول وبناء وحدات
سكنيه في ظل ارتفاع الفائده فن اعتقد انه
بالمقابل هناك انخفاض في حجم المعروض همم
هذا ادى الى يعني همم كبح وتيره انخفاض
سريع متوقع همم بسبب طبعا رفع الفائده
بالتالي لن نجد يعني النزول سريع في اسعار
العقارات
دول اخرى
حصلت فيها نفس العالم كله الان ممم يعني
يشعر بمن هناك مشكله في رفعت في رفع
الفائده لكن على مستوى العقار نجد انه
صوره مختلفه تماما يعني الاسعار الارقام
ما زالت ثابته ربما الى حد ما في مقابل
انخفاض في اسعار العقار في الدول الاخرى
طبعا الدول الاخرى عندهم معروض كبير
اعتماد كبير جدا على المعروض القائم من
الوحدات السكنيه بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه كلنا يعلم انه هناك شحف المعروض
اصلا
وبالتالي النجاح الكبير اللي حققه المملكه
خلال خمس سنوات او سبع سنوات الماضيه في
عمليه تحفيز المطورين البناء وحدات سكنيه
كان هو الحقيقه في فتره معينه وكان هذا
المعروض لا زال اقل من حجم الطلب همم بشكل
دائم وبالتالي انا اعتقادي انه همم يعني
سيكون هناك مواكبه بين حجم المعروض لان
المطورين لما يج او يخافوا من موضوع حفاظ
همم الطلب على التمويل فاكيد هيخف شويه
شهيتهم في عمليه بناء همم
هناك مقاطع
همم مدعومه هناك مشاريع وزاره الاسكان هذه
ستبقى بنفس الوتيره ونفس العده ولكن هي
تستهدف شريحه مدعومه ولا اعتقد انه مطورين
العقاريين اللي داخلين مع وزاره الاسكان
في توفير هذه الوحدات السكريه لن يتاثر
بهذا ال- ال- الارتفاع شكرا جزيلا لك
الخبير في شان العقاريه خالد شكرا شكرا
في السعوديه ايضا اصدر برنامج الاراضي
البيضاء التابعه لوزاره الشؤون البلديه
والقرويه والاسكان اكثر من
4000600 فاتوره ضمن الدوره الاولى للمرحله
الثانيه من رسوم الاراضي في مكه وجده
وحاضره الدمام البرنامج واشار الى ان
الفواتير التي صدرت شملت ثلاثه الاف 1500
ارض واقع داخل النطاق العمراني المعلم
للمرحله الثانيه موضحا بان اجماليه فواتير
رسوم الاراضي البيضاء الصادره منذ انطلاق
البرنامج
في المدن التي تمت تطبيق النظام في هدايا
الملاك الى المبادره بتطوير اراضيهم او
السادات خلال سنه من تاريخ اصدار القرار
رفعت عين السفيرتين نسرين وهيفاء الجديده
عدد السعوديات المعينات في مناصب
دبلوماسيه الى خمسه سعوديه
الى قائمه ممثلات السعوديه في سفاراتها
بالخارج السعوديه كانت قد عينت في وقت
سابق الاميره ريما بنت بندر وايناس
الشهوان وامال المعلمين في مناصب قياديه
بس الكتب الرومانسيه
التي عينه مؤخرا رئيسه البعثه السعوديه
لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي والى الجمعيه
الاوروبيه للطاقه الذريه حاصله على
الماجستير في حل النزاعات والتفاوض
بالاضافه الى درجه ماجستير ايضا في
العلاقات الدوليه فيما تم تعيين السيده
نسرين الشبل سفيره السعوديه التي سبق ان
تولت منصبه مستشار رئيس قسم او قسم مكافحه
الارهاب في البعثه السعوديه لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي مشاهدينا بالعوده الى السعوديه
شغلنا مناصب قياديه في سلك الدبلوماسيه
فان الاميره ريما بنت كانت اول سفيره
سعوديه حيث عين في فبراير من العام 2019
سفيره للبلاد في امريكا بعد ذلك عينه
اعمال المعلم سفيره للسعوديه في النرويج
في يوليو 20 20 فيما عينه ايناس الشهوان
سفيره للسعوديه في السويد في ابريل 2001
[موسيقى]
اعاده موسم شتاء السعوديه في العلا هوايه
العزف على البيانو للسائحه لبنانيه قدمت
من امريكا
من لبنان واختاروا مدينه العلا المدرجه
على دليل شتاء السعوديه لقضاء عطرتهم
[موسيقى]
لم تتصور جنا سليمان ان زيارتها السياحيه
لمدينه العلا ضمن موسم شتاء السعوديه
ستعيدها لهويتها بالعزف على البيانو بعد
انقطاعم دام لثنوات مرورها مع عائلتها
بمركز العلا الموسيقي الواقع في الاحياء
التراثيه اثار حماستها في تشجيع من
العائله
[موسيقى]
لا ما توقعت ابدا اني اسفون بس الحمد لله
مش لعبه من زمان
كمان مره
[موسيقى]
اختار العلا لجمع الابناء الذين يعيشون في
امريكا للدراسه بجدهم احمد الذي قدم من
لبنان واحب التجول في البلده القديمه
بمدينه العلا مع ابنه واحفاده
يعني انا اندعش شعر فعلا انتهت بوجودك
قالوا لي بدك تروح على شوفيه بالعلا هل في
جبيل وما جبيل قلت شو بدي اروح هلا روح
تنبس
تنبهر فعلا انبهرت بالشيء الموجود
بالتنظيم اللي عاملينه
بهالاشياء الي موجوده
القديمه رحنا جبل
الفيل رحنا احلى احلى شيء كان لطله هاي
المنطقه
كانت رائعه جدا مناظر خلابه جدا لما تشوف
العالم كلها وكل الجبال الالوان المختلفه
والغروب كان بنفس الوقت
لم يكن صعبا على اياد سليمان لم شمل
العائله من لبنان وامريكا حيث استخرج
التاشيره السياحيه للسعوديه الكترونيا
خلال دقائق معدوده
وتسعى لعائله لزياره مدن اخرى مدرجه على
دليل شتاء السعوديه من العلا نواف عزيز
العربيه
في السعوديه انطلقت المرحله الاولى من
اعمال البناء في مجمع الاستديوهات
المتكامل والمتطور في العلا التي تهدف الى
الدعم الطلب المتزايد من شركات الانتاج
الاقليميه الدوليه والاسلام في تنميه
الاقتصاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وصلت اولى دفعات فلل جزيره شيباره العائمه
الى البحر الاحمر التي تهدف الى تحقيق
الرياده السياحيه في السعوديه ضمن رؤيه
المملكه 2030
[موسيقى]
رابعه بعد قليل
الارصاد السعوديه تتوقع انخفاض في درجات
الحراره على شمال البلاد الى ما دون الصفر
المئوي
اهلا بكم في السعوديه وفي مشهد خلاب اكتست
فيه قمه جبل اللوز اللون الابيض تبدو
مظاهر الفرح بتساقط الثلوج وضحه على
الزهور حيث ادى بعضهم الفلكلور الشعبي
المعروف بالدحه اثناء التساقطات
هون هون
راح مني
[تصفيق]
نعم
تموت هوني
مركز الارصاد السعوديه اعلن عن انخفاض
درجات الحراره في معظم مناطق المملكه
ابتداء من اليوم ومن المتوقع ان تصل الى
خمس درجات في الرياض واجزاء من المنطقه
الشرقيه اما تبوك والحدود الشماليه ستسجل
صفر درجه مئويه
من اخذ المناطق في اجواء الرياض البارده
ربما من بحيره الخراره في المزاحميه انضم
الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد
هلا يا عبد الواحد
اجواء مختلفه ربما لا تعيش المزاحميه
والخراره تحديدا خلينا نشوف الصوره معك
اهلا خالد نعم طبعا كما تعرف اليوم يعني
ما في مدارس بسبب ال الحاله المطريه
بالتالي ازدحام كبير همم يعني يحيط بهذه
البحيره في المزاحميه غرب الرياض كما تعلم
هذه البحيره يعني تشكلت بسبب طبعا اجتماع
مياه الامطار اضافه الى طبعا ان هذه
البحيره تعتبر من اهم الاماكن التي يعني
ياتي اليها السكان والزوار حتى من خارج
المزاحميه
للمنتزه البري الموجود في هذا همم المكان
كما تعلم همم خالد يعني هناك اعداد كبيره
تاتي الى هذا المنتزه كما تشاهد بالصوره
همم يعني همم هناك همم البحيره على هذه
البحيره نستضيف الاستاذ بيعمل قحطاني احد
اهالي اهلا وسهلا ااا يعني لو تحدثنا عن
هذه البحيره اكيد انها يعني تشكل اهم
المعالم السياحيه لدى اهالي مزاحميه بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على
اشرف الانبياء والمرسلين بعد اشكر قناه
العربيه على تواجدها في هذا المنتزه
وحضورهم مميز لابراز مع المعالم السياحيه
في المحافظه همم شكرا لهم في كل ما عملوه
هذه البحيره هي بحيره الخراره المسماه
بحيث الخراره
تتشكل تجمع للمياه في همم
همم هذا المكان هي منتزه قديم جدا
للمحافظه كان الوصول لها في السابق من
الصعوبه الوصول لها لان كنا وانا طفل
ناتي اليها على الدواب وعلى كذا او على
الارجل مشيه من الاقدام من مزاحميه الان
الحمد لله توفرت الطرق
[ضحك]
والوصول لها فكان من السهل تواجد جميع همم
المتنزهين من الرياض من داخل المملكه من
محافظات الاخرى في هذه المكان مكان جميل
كما تشاهد شوف كميات السيارات شوف كميات
البشر طبعا هذه المياه جمعت بسبب المياه
الامطار ولا لا نعم تجمعت بسبب مياه
الامطار
هطلت قبل كم همم من عشره ايام وصار يتوالى
الخير يوما بعد يوم والحمد لله كما تشاهد
ويتجمع فيها مياه اكبر من هذا الكم لكن
عاد الحمد لله ان شاء الله جاي الليله
وبكره شكرا جزيلا لك صدام القحطاني على كل
هذه التفاصيل ولا هذه المعلومات اللي
زودتنا بها الله يعطيك الف عافيه همم كما
تشاهد خالد هذا هو المنتزه البري الذي
ياتي اليه الزوار في المزاحميه حتى وجدنا
يعني همم الناس ياتون حتى من خارج
المزاحميه للاستمتاع بهذه البحيره اضافه
الى الاجواء البارده هنا يعطيك العافيه
شكرا لك من المزاحميه مراسل العربيه عبد
الواحد عبد الحميد
اعلنت مكافحه المخدرات السعوديه عن احباط
محاوله تقريبا اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين قرص
من ماده الانفيتامين المخدر كانت مخبا في
تجاويد في الشاحنه حيث تم القبض على ثلاثه
مواطنين متورطين باستقبال الشاحنه في
منطقه الرياض والشرقيه واحالته من النيابه
العامه
العناوين
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه يعلن بدا
استعداد بلاده لاستقبال انظمه الباتريوت
الامريكيه
تصريحات متناقضه بين اجنحه النظام
الايراني حول علاقاتها وسلوكها في المنطقه
على اساس الثانوي
والارصاد السعوديه تتوقع انخفاضا في درجات
الحراره على شمال البلاد الى مادونا الصفر
والفلل العائمه لجزيره شيبارات تصل الى
مشروع البحر الاحمر في غرب السعوديه
[موسيقى]